congressman joe nagoos joins us now he
represents boulder colorado congressman
good morning to you
i can't imagine how you're feeling this
morning it's devastating and just
heartbreaking for those of us who are on
the outside looking in this must hit
very personal for you you know this area
chances are you know the story you know
the people
what went through your mind when you
heard the news it yeah it had hit so
close to home for you
uh good morning gail it's devastating
it's just it's it's
it was a devastating night last night it
was a tough night for
boulder for colorado for our country
i've
lived in boulder county for decades my
wife was born in boulder this is our
community
and our home and we're just heartbroken
at the loss of life
which is really unimaginable hard to
fathom that 10 people lost their lives
yesterday at the grocery store uh
including a police officer officer
talley who
whose heroism saved lives you tweeted
last night congress
won their loss yeah i don't mean to cut
you off but i want to make sure that we
really get to talk to you about what
happens next because you tweeted last
night enough is enough
what can what should congress do now it
seems like we have heard this song
played this record
many times before and nothing changes
yeah look gail uh colorado has been no
stranger to
gun violence and i grew up in highlands
ranch 10 minutes from my high school
the columbine tragedy unfolded when i
was 14.
two years ago my niece was a
kindergartner at the stem shooting
in highlands ranch where she was locked
down as a kindergartner
i think like many americans i feel a
great deal of anger and frustration
right now
i think the time for inaction is over it
does not have to be this way there are
common sense
gun reform legislation proposals that
have been
uh debated in the congress for far too
long and as i said i think enough is
enough and it's time for us to take
action i'm certainly going to be pushing
with my colleagues in the congress to
make that happen because i think
that as congress dithers on taking
meaningful steps americans are dying
every day coloradans are dying every day
before our eyes
and at some point we have to be prepared
to say enough is enough and i'm hopeful
that now is that time congressman we
don't yet know the details of this
particular case but the bigger picture
conversation about legislation doesn't
depend on any particular case
it depends on the politics of it i i
remember the new town
massacre and the feeling like if not now
when and yet those efforts largely came
to naught at least federally
what can you do now to make a difference
this time around
look we can't give up i mean americans
should be able to feel safe
in their grocery stores i i've gone to
this grocery store many times
they should be able to feel safe in
their schools in their movie theaters
and in their communities and so
yes as you said you know the the gun
lobby and so many others
have stopped the ability for us to make
meaningful reforms in the past but
that's no excuse
i think the american people are tired of
excuses so it's time for us to roll up
our sleeves
in the congress and muster the political
will power to actually get something
done
congressman have you heard any updates
from law enforcement uh there about what
happened
any more details you might have heard
either from there or from the governor's
office
uh we've been in touch of course with
the district attorney with the
chief of police and with the governor
i'll join the governor later this
morning for a briefing with the boulder
police and i suspect that we're all
going to learn a lot more
uh this morning when the boulder police
hold an additional media availability
and briefing i believe in
a couple hours here so obviously still
very much
you know an active crime scene there and
a lot of work to do in the days and
weeks ahead
both in terms of ensuring justice as the
district attorney so eloquently put it
but also
helping our community heal it's it's
gonna be rough
as we grieve with those families of
those who lost their loved ones
aren't you frustrated by this
congressman i look at countries around
the world that look at us and say what
is wrong with you united states of
america
i wake up this morning i keep thinking
about those 10 families who woke up and
the families in atlanta last week
whose lives are forever changed and we
keep pointing fingers at everybody else
and nothing gets done here
yeah no i i share your frustration gail
it doesn't as i said it doesn't have to
be this way this is not normal
in so many other western countries i
have a two and a half year old daughter
and i want her to grow up in a country
where she's not scared to go to the
grocery store he's not scared to go to
school
so that's certainly what motivates me
and
i i share your frustration i think a lot
of americans
share your frustrations right now we are
scared what is your message to the
boulder community today
my message is simple i i've again i know
this community i'm part of this
community and i would tell you gail that
the boulder community is strong
it is resilient it is kind and i know
that we will
uh you know ultimately come together to
support each other
and to support our community during this
very difficult time so
and our office will certainly be ready
and standing uh ready and willing and
able to help in that process
our condolences again to the boulder
community congressman joe nagooz thank
you so much for joining us this morning